i mean you've been calling for mass
testing since late march it's now late
august why are your calls seeming to
fall on deaf ears do you think
well i hope they're not and actually
this morning matt hancock the health
secretary was saying that the government
does not want to move in the direction
of mass testing and that's
to be welcomed but it's also urgent
it's because the really two things i
think we
that lie behind the desire for mass
testing
number one the majority of people who
get covered 19
are asymptomatic so in other words they
they suffer mild or no symptoms and
therefore if you're only testing the
people with symptoms you're not
capturing a large number of people who
despite being asymptomatic can
nonetheless spread the disease
so that's the first point and the second
point is that it's one thing for the
government
to permit people to do certain
activities but the question is how do
you build the confidence in the public
that they actually do those things
so you can say to people go back into
work but if they don't feel
safe then they're going to be reluctant
and if you want to reopen
schools universities workplaces if you
want
international travel to function again
the only way i think you can do that
is by doing testing at scale and that's
why we've got to move to this and you
know what we've tried to set out in the
paper which which
i signed actually not just myself but
with william hague who's my old
conservative opponent and jeremy hunt
is just to say look this is not a
political play it's just
when you look and and by the way when
you track what's happening around the
west of the world
the rest of the world this is where
people are moving they're realizing
that it's hard to get the economy
functioning again as it should
but you say that mass testing needs to
be set up now or in the month of
september to avoid a potential second
wave that could hit the uk in autumn i
mean we are running out of time
aren't we if that is the case
yeah we are running out of time and
that's why it's it's it's very urgent
now to be fair to the government it's
not that they've been doing nothing
i mean we've got the capacity now to
test about 340 000 people a day
but actually we're only using around
about 170 000 of that capacity so we're
only using about half
the testing capacity we have now so one
of the things we suggest is as you build
up
to mass testing using all the available
lab
facilities and these new rapid on the
spot tests
that we we also engage in using
the testing capacity we've already got
in order to to test more groups of
people
so for example when universities come
back you know the sensible thing
is to test the students as they come
back and do it at the halls of residence
you know there's a lot of innovation
happening in the testing space today we
set out
a whole range of the new tests that are
available some are available in this
in this country some are being developed
in the united states
i came across two just yesterday uh that
have
been cleared now by the authorities in
the u.s these are rapid on-the-spot test
that will give you the results literally
in
hours or sometimes even in a few minutes
if you're able to do that if for example
you were able to test people
as they come into the country before
they then leave the country
uh of course it would give you a much
much better way of avoiding
that the strictness of the lockdown and
the quarantine rules that are going to
do such damage to business
how concerned are you about a second
wave hitting this country and if that
happens
what will the consequences be
sorry i didn't hear that last bit emmett
yeah no we must have had
a glitch on the line let me try again
you talk about a second wave
how concerned are you of the possibility
of that happening and what would the
economic consequences be to the country
if that is the case
yeah so the the problem is that
we're not going to be able to eradicate
this disease for one thing it's
circulating globally
so you're going to have to live with it
now the risk is
as you get into the the autumn and the
winter
and the weather gets colder the days get
shorter the nights get longer
if you were to have a resurgence of the
disease you know maybe you won't but if
you were to
i think it's very hard to see how you go
back into lockdown
uh or at least without really
catastrophic economic damage i mean
already the damage from this is
is is pretty terrifying in my view and
if you can't therefore by the time you
get to the to where that
when that resurgence may happen if you
haven't got the right containment
infrastructure in place at that moment
then your risk is yes you end up with a
second wave
and then you're faced with some
absolutely impossible choices
between locking down with all the damage
that does and
keeping open with the possibility of the
disease spreading even further